on leur demande de faire état de leur
patrimoine mais ce que l'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est au fond leur demander
de ne plus avoir de vie privée
[Musique]
cette publication est totalement inutile
je ne comprends pas la raison pour
laquelle on a pu introduire autant qu'on
prend le contrôle et patrimoine autant
on ne peut pas justifier la publicité
des patrimoines la loi qui est censée
lutter contre la corruption donc entre
le vi contre le vol contre la
prévarication la loi elle est censée
inspirer par cet objectif
rosell d2 le niveau du débat et garantir
une vie politique morale elle fait le
contraire elle fait triompher
l'immoralité les sentiments les plus bas
il donne à nous tous de l'image de notre
société de notre pays de notre vie
politique ou une impression douloureuse
s'est soumis à la règle ça va ou est-ce
que ça va pas ça va mais vous avez une
espèce de nouvelles règles implicites
maintenant qui est mais de quel
patrimoine est il de propriétaires et on
compte les automobiles on compte les
appartements les mètres carrés la
surface sous plafond on se met à faire
un inventaire détaillé et cet inventaire
génère des reproches des reproches qui
ne sont pas susceptibles bien sûr d'une
sanction pénale
mais une espèce de normes sociales fixé
par on ne sait qui fonctionnant comme
une discipline qui tombe sur vous avec
des effets négatifs sur la réputation
ce que l'on fait aujourd'hui c'est au
fond leur demander de ne plus avoir de
vie privée en réalité parce que toute
vie privée sera de manière ou d'une
autre passer au tamis patrimoine c'est
la vie privée on n'a pas à connaître
tout ça et le résultat c'est que nous
aurons une classe politique plus
hypocrite encore ce n'est pas une
manière de moraliser la politique on est
plutôt en train de d'une part
j'assumerai le jeu de mots de
démoraliser la classe politique et les
élus est de faire entrer une sorte de
vis dans des procédés qui se veulent
animé par l'intention de la moralisation